pour nous l'écologie de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique doivent
rimer avec innovation avec recherche
avec recherche de deux nouvelles
solutions
donc on a une fille tu mens une vision
diamétralement opposée à celle de
emmanuel macron ce que j'observe quand
même au passage c'est que madame accroc
en réalité quand même sur ce sujet là
comme sur d'autres extrêmement peu de
conviction il réunit cette convention
citoyenne fait des grands discours et
des grandes promesses et en réalité il
abandonne en rase campagne tout ça
n'aurait été qu'un moment de
communication
nous sommes depuis quatre ans le
principal parti d'opposition
nous avons une vision de la france qui
est radicalement différente
ce quinquennat en réalité tu tournes
approche de son terme plus on arrive à
le lire il ressemble furieusement au
quinquennat précédent quinquennat de de
françois hollande et finalement ce pas
une surprise monsieur vaincrons a été le
le jeune apprenti du président landes
c'est le même déclin est connue il a
quand même attiré beaucoup de l air une
fois élus coûtent entre deux shows des
opportunistes dans la vie politique prêt
à devenir à se sacrifier pour être
ministres effectivement si ce n'est pas
notre conviction et c'est aussi pour ça
d'ailleurs que chacun doit respecter
votre compétition pour la présidentielle
enfin que qu'on peut pas tourner le dos
aux républicains parce que sont les
républicains qui ont quand même porté
cette cette opposition pendant pour
pendant quatre ans donc oui ce
quinquennat a été celui du déclin du
déclin économique d'une dette colossale
puisse plus 500 milliards d'euros de
dette est celui d'un d'un
affaiblissement permanent de l'autorité
de l'état
un laxisme en matière migratoire qui qui
sait qui c'est qui a aggravé la
situation par rapport à la situation de
françois hollande que nous n'avons
absolument rien à voir avec cette vision
de la politique